uh some breaking news to bring you and  just in the last few moments we've got  an update from northumbria university  that more than 750 students there have  tested positive  for covert 19 a spokesperson for the  university says as of friday october the  2nd  we can confirm that we're aware of 770  students who've tested positive  of whom 78 are symptomatic these  students are all now self-isolating  their flatmates and any close contacts  are also self-isolating for 14 days in  line with government guidance  and have been advised to contact nhs 119  to book a test  as soon as possible should symptoms  appear so that the breaking news from  northumbria university  you